Last year, UK charity donations fell by 1.7 billion over previous years.
And with charity collection boxes disappearing, there's even fewer opportunities for people to give.
Pennies offers a new source of funding.
It takes the old-fashioned habit of dropping a few coins in the charity box...
...and brings it up-to-date to reflect the fact we're all shopping using debit and credit card.
I think Pennies is absolutely fantastic.
I'm always using my card.
I never carry any cash with me.
Now that we've proven it in a store,...
...we really want to focus on taking it into the mobile and the online channels,...
...the fastest-growing aspects of a retailer.
I'd definitely donate pennies again this way.
With the Global Impact Award, over the next three years...
...we'd like to bring Pennies to the mobile and Internet channel,...
...raising seven million pounds for many UK charities.
Our vision: whether you'll be shopping in a store, online, using your mobile device,...
...you should be given the option to donate a few pennies to charity.